[Music]
hey could we go back to the part about
the ghosts
cuz wait a minute are
you it's nearly Christmas there are
three of you oh good you get it I'm
future she's past and you are Ghost of
Christmas
present I'm still here
toots
Jeepers who's the Valentine know
so do you see
this the
woodwork um why don't you go inside you
know take a closer
look
okay why can't he see you question is
why can you see
me you live here that's right don't you
know it's haunted a bewitching woman You
Can Do Magic right well everybody can do
magic has brought a little mystery she's
a witch a real live which welcome to
Ireland wow your uncle is aan McCarthy
such a tragic accident accident what do
you think really
happened dead thought I
am what are you want for me to solve my
or's Marg during that time I was
connected with some girls and I remember
going to a sleepover and they watched a
movie called The Craft and this movie
came out uh around 1996 and it was about
four witches who were in high school
whatever you do stay away from them why
they're witches and these witches were
bullied and picked on and their lives
were kind of messed up and they used
witchcraft to control situations around
them and to get what they wanted or
girls are about to discover the dark
side you ever heard of invoking the
spirit black
magic we can make things happen I mean
this is it this is real
I watched the movie and I thought I want
that well of course in the movie they
went too far anyway and the Witchcraft
had turned against them and the girls
were desperate to get out of it but
during that point I didn't even see that
ending I just thought oh I won't go that
far I'm just going to be innocent in it
and I began to study the religion of
Wiccan and study um different spells and
incantations and New Age practices and
occult practices that I was was doing in
a Christian home that nobody knew I was
doing and so what started off as
something innocent where I'm just
connecting with energy and the universe
and Vibes and all these innocent things
that we see took me down a path of just
dark
desperation um I I felt at one point
that I was living in like a haunted
house because I was hearing scratches on
the wall right next to me I would feel
brushed by me and be terrified that
somebody is here in the room with me
someone watching me I always felt like I
was being watched when I would wash my
face for the day it was one of the most
terrifying things that I did when I took
a shower and I had to close my eyes I
was so terrified if I had to get up in
the middle of the night to get a glass
of water I would run because I thought
something's going to grab my feet I was
an adult at this point and it took me
far into drugs um I ended up being
homeless and on drugs in and out of
jails and all kinds of things for 9
years of my life I was really in a dark
place I think media has done a a a good
job of pushing something to the point
where it is now normalized when back in
the day something like that for you and
I it would be shocking to
see and now because we have shows as
early as you know daycare age promoting
Witchcraft and sorcery and it's okay
boys and girls say these spell words
with us and it's so ABC preschool
witchcraft that it gets into the hearts
and the minds of people including the
people in church and people who are are
not really connected with the Lord and
don't understand they're easily deceived
and the Bible talks about even the very
elect will be deceived and so people are
going to a whole another source that's
what they're they wanting they want a
healing Crystal because they don't
understand that Jesus is the Healer and
there's no other source that you can go
to except through Jesus and so I I'm
seeing a rise of this I'm seeing it
become very trending on Tik Tok and
things like that and there's a whole
generation of people who I feel like are
being rocked to sleep by the enemy and
it's just really time for the church
like what you're doing doing this
interview to sound the alarm and say no
we need to wake up and we need to say
this is not right it's not for my home
it's not for my kids a Hallmark Channel
original movie do you believe in ghost
Clyde R has been dead for over 40 years
a young boy I really was somebody up
here he's real an old spirit I can't
actually leave the
[Music]
house